[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I think we are live now so hey everyone
welcome to the first Techwood Lucy live
stream today I'm here with Jerry a
senior recruiter and we're going to be
answering all your questions on how to
become a Solutions architect the skills
required how to Ace your Solutions
Arctic interview and much more but
before we get started please let us know
in the chat where you're tuning in from
so I'm based in Sydney Jerry is in
Singapore and we'd love to know where
you are as well and also comment below
where you are on your Cloud Journey
I see yeah we have a few comments and
questions coming in already so what
we'll do for today's session is we've
actually gathered some questions before
the live stream and collated five common
questions that we've been getting from
the subscribers and we're going to be
answering those five questions but also
the questions from the live stream as
well so feel free to pop in any
questions that you have for Jerry for
today's session
yep I see here that we have people from
us UK San Diego
Indonesia as well nice and then Nigeria
USA Colombia Canada
wow yeah kind of like all over the world
so yep hey Jerry how are you doing today
I'm good how are you good morning to you
Lucy
yeah doing good it's morning for both of
us right oh it's 12 p.m here for me what
time is it for you in Singapore
it's 9 A.M and uh good afternoon good
evening to whoever you know wherever
you're dining from
nice okay so to start off with
do you want to give a bit of a
background about yourself like your
career Journey uh what you do at AWS and
you know after that we can move on to
the questions
sure sounds good
um yeah thank you so much Lucy for
inviting me I'm really excited to be
here on this live channel uh sharing
some some of the experiences uh
interview tips answer any questions uh
you may have so a little bit myself I've
been you know in the recruiting HR space
for over 12 13 years I actually started
out with a business function
um but you know I worked across a few
tech companies ranging from startups to
big companies currently I'm with AWS
epjc Talent acquisition team
and I hire mostly for the tech Rose yeah
so I think uh happy to answer some of
the questions you may have today if I
don't have the time to answer it uh you
can you know easily find me online
through Linkedin or other social medias
feel free to connect with me always drop
me a message I'm happy to answer all
your questions
awesome and thanks so much for joining
today I know it's always good to have a
perspective of a recruiter because you
know a lot of these YouTube videos that
I make it's all from mainly my personal
experience and the research that I've
been able to gather you know by talking
with other Solutions Architects but it's
great to be able to have you know I've
seen a recruiter on the show who hires
for Solutions Architects to answer some
of the interview questions and you know
questions that the viewers might have
around you know how to write a resume uh
what skills to build and things like
that so let me just share this slide
these are actually the five questions
that we've gotten
um or like there were much like there
were many more questions but these were
the top five so what we're gonna do is
uh we're gonna be answering these five
questions but in the meantime as well
yeah feel free to put your questions in
the chat and we'll get to them as well
so Jerry
from the perspective of a recruiter awas
what is the interview process like and
do you mind sharing a bit as well what
you look for in candidates when you hire
for Solutions architects
sure sounds good
um so I think there are sort of numerous
resources out there online today right
whether it's through our career website
to you know uh some content from uh
Lucy's channels
um I think this topic has been talked uh
quite often so and I think there's sort
of really no one-size-fits all
um from a kind of recruiting function
standard point of view it depends on you
know your job level it uh that you're
applying for it depends on the country
you're applying for it depends on the
role
um that you're applying for as well even
you know under the solutions architect
umbrella we have a few categories like
for example the majority that would hire
is generalists type of solutions
architect but sometimes we hire
um sort of specialist type of essays as
well partner essays as well
um so it varies but I would say you know
typically it wouldn't Escape those four
components right which is your phone
screen which is uh usually the first
rounds that you will explain is one or
two and then there will come the
assessment
so the assessment could be a take-home
assessment
or it could be a case study uh and then
usually there will be a written
assignment as well a writing portion of
it that you know that you have to submit
before you present or submit before your
on-site interview and lastly I think you
know we will all go through a final
round which is a what we call a loop
interview that is very targeted on the
Amazon leadership principles that you're
going to interviewing with a few uh
interviewers right whether it's within
uh the Future Organization you're going
to work for as well as outside and there
will be a mixture of their functions as
well as a bar raiser this is probably
something very unique about Amazon and I
think there are many many resources you
can read online about this unique
interview process
um in terms of you know what what I
looking for
um in kind of Illusions architect right
I would say it is a really mixture so
Solutions architect is a job family if
you just go online as well on our on you
know the LinkedIn search that you would
find our Solutions architect right it
also comes from various backgrounds uh
and sometimes they come from a kind of
you know obviously a very
straightforward is a kind of a
competitive background uh they were
already doing kind of a Solutions
archetype role before sometimes it can
come from a sort of a system uh engineer
background or startup CTO
um you know engineering heads uh they're
thinking of making us a career switch or
actually sometimes you know they they
they were coming from a like a business
background uh that's also possible as
long as you you know you can have the
technical are skill sets so really a
wide range of it but one thing I wanted
to emphasize is that so Solutions
architect is a title that I think it
means very different things in you know
different companies uh sometimes it
could mean post sales I know some
solutions architecting some companies
that do end to end from pre-seals to
delivery sometimes there is Enterprise
solutions to architect you're dealing
mostly with more complex and larger
accounts sometimes there's Business
Solutions architect that usually you
know your sort of internal essay
so for us as AWS essay you are part of
the pre-sales team so you would be sort
of hands off uh once you know your
initial architecture design in the POC
stage is done uh then you know your
partner or uh AWS Professional Services
team will be carrying out the
implementation
um so making sure that you're aware of
that so because since it is a sort of a
pre-sales role right so then obviously
there are some components related to the
pre-seals that we will be looking for
and I think that will be probably the
next question yeah so I'll go into the
depths around that later yeah
amazing yeah I feel like he answers so
many of the questions uh just by that
one response so you covered the
interview process you know you mentioned
that Solutions Architects can come from
many different backgrounds doesn't even
have to be a technical background people
come from all sorts of career paths and
at AWS they also hire people from many
different levels right not just people
who have many years of experience but
also for example associate Solutions
architects so before we move on to the
next question on the slide I'd like to
just have a look at the audience
questions first so we have a question
from Kuma so Kuma says that
um
they have four years of java background
experience with zero experience in the
cloud and they passed the solutions
Arctic associate and developer exam and
wondering how they can apply for
positions because companies hire for
experienced people so I guess we can
talk a bit about you know like
AWS hiring for associate Solutions
Architects right and you know having the
certifications really help you stand out
in the application process so yeah Jerry
what are your thoughts on this
So yeah thank you Kuma for the question
and uh
um speaking someone with no experience
you've already got four years of
experiences right
so I think um absolutely right uh you
you know uh looking into Solutions
architect
um what I would uh you know looking to
maybe associate Solutions architect or
Solutions architect as uh you know a job
family to start with I think typically
we we do see you know Solutions
architect we see like a five plus years
background but associate Solutions
architect you know uh sometimes it will
hire them fresh uh from college after
they graduate
um and uh you know and since you already
got the certificate right it definitely
helps uh greatly with you know applying
for the job I think uh in terms of like
the interview process and what you
should prepare I think you know those
are um probably the later questions we
will cover as well yeah so for the
beginning I would say definitely go
ahead and apply yeah
um yeah definitely
um because speaking from my personal
experience as well I started off as an
associate Solutions architect uh there
are many colleagues who have had menus
of years of experience as a Solutions
architect already or as a software
developer but from my experience you
know AWS does give you the training and
the guidance for you to you know learn
from more senior people you know Shadow
and then there's also opportunities
internally to do like training and keep
getting you know more certifications and
hands-on experience so yeah definitely
go for it
the next question we have or there's a
few questions actually around
internships so people are asking where
they can apply for internships and uh
another question on can you jump from an
internship straight into an essay role
that's uh some I think some of the
questions I don't have this answer as of
now uh you know uh at this point but
usually I think if you look at our
website or some of our campus events
that we're hosting around the world uh
you will usually see internship
opportunities I would you know whether
the possibility right of converting from
intern to a full-time
um there's no guarantee but I would say
uh really the likelihood it was very
strong right uh if you I mean Lucy I
think herself is coming from intern to a
full time as well uh obviously if you
you know join us for an intern
um background to your you know already
participating in some more projects
you're already you know build up that
network uh with the internal resources
you can leverage later on it definitely
help right
um but whether it's like an immediate
conversion it it depends on you know the
the availability of that role at that
particular point right uh whether you're
what they're looking for what you know
your background is
um but you know if you're interested in
AWS if you're a student today uh looking
to gaining some project experiences or
experiences with AWS Cloud I would say
internship is a great way to start
yeah I agree I love internships because
they're a way for you to learn you know
from the company in a short amount of
time and also just for you to assess
whether the role is right for you as
well uh because like you know if you go
into the role as a full-time and then
you realize it's not something you want
to do then it's harder to switch
compared to if you had an internship
that was let's say four weeks long and
then after the afterwards you decide to
pursue a different role so yeah
internships are a great way to start off
um in the tech world and in the cloud
industry there are solutions Architects
interns that I've seen at AWS so yeah I
would say yeah same with Jerry um just
keep an eye out on the AWS and Amazon
job portal to see if there's any open
positions coming up you know when you're
ready to apply
uh yeah let's move back to the questions
that we have on the slide because uh
this is one that I think would be quite
helpful for a lot of people so what are
some soft skills and technical skills
needed to become a Solutions architect
right so I think uh this question again
Ray it's probably covered by many many
uh resources already uh I would say
typically it's the two sides right
really the kind of the the technical uh
side of things as well as you know soft
skills or cultural side of things uh
that we're looking at
um and then things you know the
solutions Architects we um said in the
beginning it's a pre-sales role at AWS
so
um obviously the communication skills
right that uh that you're able to
present to the clients you know
providing a consultative approach to the
clients those soft skills are quite
essential for the technical right side
of things we're looking for
um it depends again really on your on
your job level right that you're
applying for uh typically for experience
higher we're looking for me the both the
depths and the breath and then the
breasts right it could spin across um
you know the core Services uh uh AWS is
offering right from compute storage data
analytics networking
um and the depths right that you know uh
one to two areas you're quite strong at
and there could be an area to be honest
that it is a blockchain for example or
machine learning right that you're
strong at we don't typically uh try to
like uh eliminate people uh you know is
um
is particularly strong in just one area
that uh that is not you know whether
it's infra or application
um we are we're giving that sort of a
flexibility and freedom uh for you to
you know demonstrate your uh your strong
areas unless you know it is a specialist
uh role or specify that you know we're
kind of purely looking for a you know
oracle Focus uh essay today so for
journalists I I think usually you know
it's a depths and breasts uh that you
know there will be assessments
surrounding those questions as well uh
later on in your architecture design
um for the other side right uh the soft
skills
um the the leadership principles right
which is a very big uh interview
um component with us uh I would say
um you know
familiarize yourselves right with all
the uh leadership principles that we
have because those are you know there
will be observed and then assess really
throughout the interviews all right so
when you in the big from the beginning
when when you started a phone interview
with us or later on going to the
technical rounds
um maybe they're there aren't any sort
of Behavioral based questions but the
way how you deliver yourself how you
articulate hey why do I want to join AWS
how do you propose that architecture how
do you solve on summer problems those
are also the data points really we are
collecting to see are you you know for
example earning trust are you learn and
be curious you know those are the the
leadership principles LP in short uh uh
that we are you know using some of those
data points to make a decision later
right and then I would say
um um you know goes back to the last
point of the communication skills that
we're looking for
um so there is a peculiar way how you
know Amazon uh internally communicates
and writes as well uh if you're uh you
know curious what that means right
narrative writing what that means for
you know one pager six page or those
dark writing uh feel free to check out
our career website we have a section
focusing on that as well typically I
think you know whether it's your written
a size assessment whether it's your
interviews right on the actual days uh
making sure
um that you speak or write in a very
concise and data-driven um way
um because that is what we are looking
for yeah
great I love the last point that you
mentioned uh interviewing is definitely
a skill sometimes you might have all the
soft skills and technical skills
required but it's another whole skill to
Showcase that in an interview so you
know making sure you have those data
points and making sure you're able to
answer in you know the staff format or
like in a way that's easy for your
interviewer to understand
um and really just be able to convey the
point across so yeah really good advice
there
um let's move on to another question we
have from the chat so
this question is around someone who is
studying for their comp tier a plus and
they're planning to get more I.T
certifications so Network plus Security
Plus uh before getting an AWS
certification so yeah the question is
should I stick straight to this or go
right into AWS and I think this question
is probably mainly asking about you know
whether you need all the it fundamentals
down pat before you get started with
like you know studying for an AWS
certification
um my personal perspective is that you
know the cloud practitioner
certification it doesn't really require
you know like a strong background in it
like you can straight away you know do
like a video course and then you know
you'll be able to you know like
understand most of the concepts because
they kind of assume that you don't have
like many years of experience either way
it's a foundational certification it
would be helpful though to get some
experience you know understanding at
least what the cloud is what networking
and security is uh yeah do you have any
thoughts around that as long jury
yes in fact I do so as if yesterday I
just passed my cloud practitioner
certificate last night yeah and I
personally did not come from Attack
backgrounds right uh I think there are a
variety of certifications uh that we are
providing today that's targeting for you
know different demographics
um
um I find that you know just like Lucy
said right uh um you know the cloud
practitioner you know that certificate
doesn't go very in depth in the
technical side of things uh you know
once you go through the training you
read through some more white papers
um and there are numerous you know
online resources you can find uh you
could basically grasp the overview of
you know what uh AWS Solutions some of
our technology offerings uh and then you
will be able to get some of the
certifications and then as always right
so that notifications is a great way to
start your interview with AWS although
it is not a must-have but it definitely
you know shows you're curious you have a
strong interest with um you know our
Cloud Computing Services yeah
yeah and what I like about
certifications as well it's you know
when people want to start off with the
cloud they don't know what to study like
what services to read up on or like you
know what service to experiment or build
with but then what certifications does
is that there are a lot of video courses
that map out like a learning plan so
even if you don't take the certification
you can still go through that curriculum
and then get a strong you know Cloud
fundamentals you know like let's say if
you do the solutions Arctic associate or
even Cloud practitioner
the next question I think this is a
great question from Victor so what makes
a candidate Stand Out Jerry so you know
when you've seen several candidates
already go through interviews from your
experience what do you think makes a
standout candidate
um what so I would say you know it
depends on the few stages right from the
application stages to the interview
stages
um to all the way right maybe the offer
stage as well uh from the application
stage right that um obviously you know
uh the first
um you know impression that we have is
your resume right uh and then making
sure you know uh uh
um again right when we are going back to
the AWS uh sorry Amazon leadership
principles right
um dive deep uh Ray uh earn trust right
those are some of those leadership
principles can also apply to your resume
writing right so if I'm looking at a
resume with just really a cluster of
experiences you know not highlighting
anything everything is very generic high
level so those are probably you know can
have some room for for improvement
development right versus a resume it is
very concise straight to the point very
data driven with some of the data points
created listed out in your achievements
um this you know definitely don't helps
with your interviews as well right when
you're thinking about how do I answer
this Behavior interview questions what
are some of the past projects I've done
that I could leverage on those datas
right and then and then communicate and
present in a very concise way so I would
say throughout
um you know the process right right from
the beginning when you're applying that
you're very uh you have done your
research right you know what you're
you're going at uh you know what are the
some of the differences uh and then you
know you get prepared in interviews uh
you know you present yourself well and
then these are all the all of the the
process right I would say uh leadership
principle right is part of the a very
important a component that we're looking
for so ma'am making sure you know if you
you set up your mind you're thinking
about hey AWS is a is an organization I
want to give a try I would suggest that
you know start earning
um to conduct research know about what's
going on uh not necessarily going into
maybe the last stage of the loop
interview that you start a research on
hey how do you how do I interview with
AWS because really throughout the way
right whether we are asking direct
questions or we are just observing you
know if you are you have something
Amazonian attributes
um everything that you put out right uh
is a way for um for us right to think of
it but at the same time I also you know
I always encourage candidates to to you
know you should be your own judge as
well right and interviews should always
be a two-way straight
um
conversations and it should be how we uh
always be a two-way street decision
making as well so you have a chance to
you know research the Amazon uh
interviewing with us and then you know
make a decision to say hey if this
culture really does work for me or not
a lot of pretty good tips there
um I
was trying to say you know a lot the
interview starts before the actual
interview so you know you have to make
your resume tailored to the job
description making sure you have the
experiences that you potentially want to
talk about in the interview because you
know recruiters do have a copy of your
resume before they do the phone screen
and you know that in the interviewers
usually will have a copy as well uh yes
a really good advice there one thing I
wanted to add Lucy is that you know
um that uh the recruiter is actually
seeing candidates applying to multiple
rows which is completely fine right at
Amazon because it's a very large
organizations however if we're seeing
that you've applied for software
engineer apply for HR Marketing sales
all at a certain period of time right
sometimes this could create a big
confusion as what exactly are you
looking for or you're looking to develop
your career into
um and then you know sometimes we've
also seen people applying for thousands
of jobs
um so I would really strongly encourage
right every application that you make
um don't just think hey it's gonna be
like a black hole uh I don't know you
know they will I will hear back so if I
see this interesting I'm going to try it
out do some research uh before you apply
because it will you know it it it it is
it can stays as a record in our system
right so throughout the years we can all
always see that oh you've applied for
this you've applied for that location
um and then you know so just to avoid
the confusions uh for yourself as well
right I would encourage that you know
you do a bit of research before you
initiate the application yeah
um yeah a lot about the quality of the
application rather than just you know
the quantity applying to as many places
as possible uh yeah a lot of questions
as well in the chat now around how do
you get started with AWS as a beginner
how do you build skills and you know
like if you don't have a college degree
can you still get into AWS or like if
you don't have it experience so I think
we can try and answer those questions
maybe all in one response which is you
know like if let's say you're a complete
beginner to it and the cloud how can you
build the relevant skills in order to
get into AWS
uh I I think that question was uh like a
extension of that a very interesting
question we got Lucy right
um that that was a question hey how do I
uh build our Cloud uh skills I'm a
teenager high school today and I love uh
this question uh well and then first of
all thank you so much right for your
interest with uh with cloud computing
with AWS in general right uh even if if
you're in high school you're already
planning ahead uh it's so great I think
you have a very strong start to begin
with
um I think
um really no matter you know what uh
background you're coming from
um and then AWS as an organization today
right it's also we don't just hire for
tech people right we hire for marketing
we hire for sales we have for various uh
rows so and then you are you might be
interested in the tech rules or you
might find yourself doing something else
uh that's more suitable to you so I
would say you know Tech background is
absolutely you know not a must-have and
even if Ray that that you you said hey
I'm coming from a non-tech but um you
know I've gained the cloud projects
experiences
um um even though I don't have like a
computer science degree uh we have seen
numerous uh examples of that going into
solution architect even going to
Engineers uh right so it is not a
prerequisite to have a attack background
um but I would say right
um if you wanted to begin
um
uh this journey
um Number One Thing Ray is definitely uh
start to get yourself familiarized right
with the okay what is cloud computing
right what is that what are the benefits
um what are the projects right that that
you know that's beneficial from clouds
that I could get a bit Hands-On whether
it's the personal projects that have
school assignments uh and uh you know
getting some of the certifications along
the way right uh if you're interested in
AWS great get some AWS certifications
um
subscribe to some more
industry-wide you know sort of blogs
events you know papers there are many of
them around cloud computing uh AWS we
produce uh you know a large amount of
those materials that you can easily
digest and read and then up to date
events recently we hosted reinvent at
Vegas
um so those are the you know great
channels right to just familiar yourself
uh with you know what's going on in this
industry right and making connections uh
networking potentially uh with very
experienced people who is already
working in the channel uh you know in in
this sector right getting a mentor if
you have the resources that would be
great as well
um but of course lastly right you have
to watch Tech with Lucy uh that you know
it's uh the most
um important channel right you should
definitely subscribe and there's a lot
of great tips and contents yeah
thanks Jerry uh I like how you mapped
out like a road map for our students and
you know people early in their career or
you know just car beginners on how they
can start their career with AWS coming
from their experience you know you
mentioned certifications first and then
projects uh you know like looking at
like the different roles available and
then also you know doing some networking
and potentially getting a mentor in Tech
so yeah those those are some really good
steps to bring you closer to getting a
job at AWS and in a technical role
um
I think this covers question number four
as well that we have on the slide so you
know like I got an AWS certification
what's next and yeah there's been a
question in the chat as well on is it
possible to get a job after getting the
cloud practitioner certification so do
you have any more advice Jerry on how
people can you know go about their
learning after getting certified
yeah so well first of all right I I have
to emphasize that you know certification
is not a prerequisite
um for applying to us
and uh uh but it's always you know
definitely nice to have right and then
uh you know uh once you have a
certification it shows uh your interest
right uh from the start with AWS and now
after getting the the certificates right
um uh obviously you know it's a it's a
great way that to demonstrate that hey
you have the fundamental uh fundamental
knowledge right the foundationals of
some of the AWS Services
um however if you are you know an
experienced hire that that you know uh
that you're applying today right your
project experiences right your Hands-On
project experiences your experience with
Cloud it could be AWS it could be
something it could be other Cloud
providers as well those are very very
important right your concept the
architecture design uh your you know the
technical depths that you could go into
in each of the areas uh so those are I
would say much much more
um you know important in the actual
interviews
um so I would say if you are you know uh
kind of interested in that in that
Journey right uh wherever you are uh to
get yourself into a kind of a position
that could hung in uh those experiences
those skill sets it could be like an
engineer role it could be a system
design role
um or it could be the project school
projects that you're working on right so
those are I would say A you know very
strong data points right later on that
you could demonstrate yourself with and
then you get sort of really Hands-On
experiences with yeah
awesome so speaking of you know you
mentioned like like system and engineer
like you know different backgrounds
um someone asked how do you know which
path in the cloud to follow as there are
multiple and yeah in the channel as well
like I've tried to explain the different
roles in AWS like there's not just
Solutions Architects but there's also
Cloud Engineers Cloud Architects and a
whole bunch of roles right in Marketing
sales Talent acquisition like yeah just
across all the different fields right so
how would what advice would you have for
people who are trying to figure out like
you know what role is right for them and
what role they should be aiming for
okay so this is not AWS specific
question
I would say uh if you have a question of
what you wanted to do with your life
right I would say uh that there are some
of the assessments that you could take
as well right uh like you know your
personality uh tests uh what type of
roles that you're suitable uh with right
is it customer facing is it more you
know sort of a research standard Rose
um I think the um this probably you know
whether you are in school right
um
getting
um
the mentors advising you talking to
right some of the people who's actually
working on those roles that you're
interested in to say hey how is your
day-to-day like right uh what are the
things that you like what are the things
you hate about your work and then sort
of reflecting to yourself to say hey
what are my strengths uh you know am I
really suitable right for a role like
that uh if you're somebody you know for
example who's um kind of more interested
in just doing
um that you know the technical work
you're not very
um you know bothered with the people's
side of things right so I would say in
general like the architect that job
family right is uh you know whether
you're pre-sales and post sales it's
going to be a lot of people interactions
customer facing right uh um you know
stakeholder management right so that
that could be uh not you know a role
that you could rethink about hey you
know where am I suitable or not but I I
would say you know uh it is a very big
question uh which which row is suitable
for you I would say uh do some
self-exploration right and then the best
way is always you know getting
internship experiences getting some
project experiences try it out yourself
talking to the people who's working on
these rows and then start reflecting
right to see hey if this is interesting
for me and then you could you know
probably go through some hurdles as well
along your career you may try this you
find that hey it's not you know for me
right I think yeah this is not me or to
be honest after you're married after you
have kids your priorities change you
know your your personal experience to
change as well to be honest so your
personal development is also very
Dynamic right it doesn't have to be like
hey you know my 30 years I have to do
this one row at the same time you can
experiment and then your you know your
strengths would play out as well because
you are in the development Journey
yourself
so I would say
um do some constant Reflections right
you know definitely focusing on the the
the the moment that we call like uh
you're in the in the moment of uh flow
right you're really enjoying what you're
doing like inclusive for example I think
she's definitely really enjoying uh
doing YouTube channel right she's doing
outside of her work as well
um so yeah focusing on those and then
think breaking down the elements like
why do I enjoy doing this
um and then what are the potential jobs
right that has similar attributes uh of
those things that I really enjoy and
then putting together and it cannot it
doesn't have to be a hundred percent
right as long as there's 80 as long as
there's you know a high level that I
think I enjoy doing it that's great yeah
um yeah great advice uh sometimes
there's a lot of pressure to find like
the ideal path or like the ideal career
for you but as you mentioned you know
careers are never linear like I started
off as an associate Solutions Arctic but
now it's on YouTube which is you know
technically like a completely different
field but I was able to use a lot of the
skills from my career you know in Tech
into you know providing advice on
YouTube so yeah I've seen a lot of
people just go from various Industries
and various roles and moving internally
at AWS was something that I've saw was
quite common as well like if you find a
role that you're more passionate about
internally there's always opportunities
for you know mobility within the company
so yeah I think it would be really great
to cover that this last question we have
on the slide which is what's a typical
career path for an essay which we both
know at this point there's not really a
typical path or like a most I guess
there's a most common path or like a
more traditional path you know like
where people can either go into like
management or like a more technical role
like a principal essay so yeah Jerry
Jonah provides some insights on I guess
that typical career path
yeah so I think this is not just limited
to uh essay uh as a job family right it
is very much a you know a great
um you know Amazon culture that we have
is uh you know we really encourage
um sort of multitude right of uh
development uh you know your growth it
could be linear uh vertical horizontal
uh you know it could be multi Lanes
right that you can develop so for essay
for example it could be you know
increase your job scope at a higher
level right uh if your essay today you
develop yourself to senior essay
um so on so so uh forward right and then
you're if you're quite very much enjoy
the kind of the the IC individual
contributor type of uh role then that's
probably your track right the technical
Specialist or if you're interested you
know uh in people management mentoring
coaching you know
um future Generations colleagues right
you could look at into management you
could be an essay manager uh but as as
well as you know we've seen that you
know for Solutions arcade and
transitioning into the sales account
role uh which is previously their
counterparty right account manager pair
with a sort of essay uh they do that
transition as well uh they want to see
what's going on uh over there it could
be you know a different area that
previously you're focusing very much on
Healthcare that you're interested in I
don't know like financial services that
you know there's possibility there uh
and then you know in the technical side
if you have been working on databases or
along that you're interested in
um
I know container right uh there's
definitely you know specialist container
team there's projects uh very much
needed container skills that you can
hone your skills right and then when
when the uh when the moment is ready you
can make that transition l or it could
be a completely different role right
I've seen that uh I've seen I haven't
seen sa but I've seen developers uh many
that that they're interested that you
know they've been developing after 10
years uh writing codes right they say
hey I I wanted to do something with
people so they they transitioned to be a
recruiter and they're very good you know
they know all those really the
architecture design technicals is much
better than us right for me like not
coming from a technical background
um and I think you know Amazon is a
great way because it's a it's a you know
it's a very large umbrella with a
variety of stages of organization and
the categories of businesses right even
within AWS Excel with we serve you know
um from the the early stage startup all
the way to government multinational
firms you have many many opportunities
right even if that it is not your
kind of like you don't even get need to
get promoted to try out even within that
job right you get the chance to just
participate in some of our projects and
to see hey if I like it or not so I
would say it's very very multi uh
aptitude yeah
mm-hmm yeah so speaking of promotions I
see there's a question I think I saw a
question around
um how promotions work at AWS I think or
you know if there's ways to uh yeah if
there's promotion opportunities in AWS
Associated to kind of move on to the
next role like from associate Solutions
architect to Solutions architect don't
share a bit of insight around that
so
um yes I think uh but I think I I could
share to a certain extent right because
it is a little bit of a company specific
um questions uh there are every company
to be right is that you know I think
there's probably no company in the world
that you know we we hire somebody we
want you to grow right we we want to see
you develop yourself we want to see you
do a better job right that's how your
you know contribute back to the company
as well so promotion is a great way
right uh to recognize some of the
efforts
um so I mean uh obviously you know
Amazon we have a routine of what we call
14 right a yearly review process as well
that we're looking at you know the
potentials that you're demonstrating uh
we are you know uh it's also very
Dynamic I think you know with Amazon
structure it's a little bit more flat
comparing to some of the industry
players I would say in terms of the job
leveling and then you would say you know
sometimes we give people a chance right
to to try out those rows or the next
level job roles already right if they're
performing at that level then why not
then they should really get promoted
right away right so we always encourage
your career development is your own uh
uh you should own it right you are the
owner of your own personal development
where you want to go uh you know uh and
they and they shouldn't always be just
there's one pass right it should be
tailored towards you on the exact point
whether you're looking at yeah
um yeah that's a trend I've seen as well
that it is it's definitely different
between the different companies uh
there's been some companies where I
think the promotion is based on like the
time you're in the role for like I think
sometimes like they go from analyst to
consultant after two years uh so
different companies have different ways
of how they measure their performance
but yeah it is very much like you know
your career is something that you own
and that you try and work with your
manager or your team to try and figure
out what's next for you and you know
what other opportunity or skills you
want to build in your next role
um so
I think yeah so we've covered all the
questions on this slide but there's
still a few more coming into the chat
I'm just conscious of time because we're
planning to wrap up soon
um but yeah let's pick a few questions
and see what else people have asked so
this question is around what's the least
number of projects recommended to
capture the eyes of recruiters for
applicants so what I'm what I'm thinking
this question is asking is you know on a
resume how much experience or like
Hands-On projects do you need to kind of
be accepted to the next round I know
it's a very um it's a very Case by case
spaces right do you have some advice
around that I would say as much as you
can get
there is definitely no minimum uh
there's no maximum as well but I would
say
um besides the number of projects right
also focusing on the depths right
because when we are starting asking the
behavioral based interview questions uh
if you are familiar with it you know
it's tell me a situation
um that you know you've demonstrated
some certain behaviors right so we are
looking for you to give a story about
that particular situation right with the
beginning with the Middle with and you
know follow like a star the situation
task action results type of format so if
you can you know
um demonstrate right uh like for example
a leadership role in the project right
that would be very fantastic uh I
wouldn't necessarily think it's a
quantity it's a quality right and then
how in depth that you can go into those
projects because those are the times
that the interviewers will be following
up right hey so what is your role in
that project or you know if you're given
the chance again how would you do it
differently
um you know what do you think that was
your part of your failure right so
really I would think
um developing you know those kind of
like uh meaning for uh stories or
episodes of your projects right is much
much more critical and important yeah
awesome there's another question in the
chat around job interviews so
um I think this is what is mainly just
asking about kind of
when people would lie in their interview
or kind of make up stories
um I think yeah what are your thoughts
on that you know is it is that something
you can tell in an interview you know
something you would recommend or you
know like yeah I think it would be great
to hear from a recruiter perspective
um okay yes so uh I was I think these is
a definitely a No-No for us okay
um but uh like if you are a great
Storyteller that you can just make up uh
for something you know out of the thing
there and then you are flawless right
that I don't think there is a like 100
way to detect it but through from my
experience usually if you're making up
something if you've not done it right or
is somebody else doing it you are just
part of that story
um you uh it's kind of it's not thought
tolerant so once we have follow-up
questions we ask specifically hey what
is your role in it you know or some of
the areas that you mentioned you know
machine learning areas for example that
can you elaborate a bit more right is
that those are the times that people um
started to make mistakes or they they
stumble or uh you know they cannot
really answer so I would say
um
try not to
you know uh yeah kind of make up stories
right in fact that uh being honest right
um being the you know quite
straightforward to the things that you
know or you don't know is a way uh at
least at Amazon that we appreciate right
because it's a sign of earned trust so
when we are asking you that you know an
area that you're not familiar with uh
rather than just kind of starting a
mumbling or you know uh pacing out
whatever you know information that you
have to to think hey this might be a
correct answer we'd rather you just say
straightforwardly sorry I'm not an
expert uh in this area and then we are
not really expecting you know you to be
an expert in all the areas right so I
would say being honest uh is very
important whether it's you know and
you're going through Amazon interviews
or any other type of job interviews
right in any other companies yeah
and uh definitely and yeah that's part
of you know like one of the red flags
right that you know recruiters might
spot in a candidate if you know you ask
something and you realize the story
might be made up or you can see people
in a technical interview if they're like
Googling their answers and like you know
typing
um the question and trying to get an
answer and just reading off Google for
example uh there's quite a few you know
things to avoid doing to really show
authenticity in an interview and just be
kind of like show the best version of
what you know and your experiences
let me just have a look at the chat uh
we have a few more questions so sorry
everyone if we didn't get a chance to
answer some of the questions that you
asked I tried my best to answer you know
ask the questions that were the most
commonly
um you know commented on in the chat but
yeah any other questions feel free to
leave it down in the comments after the
recording and feel free to connect with
Jerry as well you know follow Jerry on
LinkedIn but yeah Jerry so we have a
couple minutes left um and I just want
to ask you one final question so for
people who are interested in the
solutions Arctic role which I'm assuming
is most people in the chat what is your
biggest advice for them as like a Next
Step uh you know if they're looking to
learn a role as a Solutions architect in
2023
uh that's uh yeah I would say a bit of
summary right uh of uh you know
everything that uh we talked about today
um um a few things right number one is I
think uh definitely do your research
right
um that uh if you already know hey
preservation architect role is a
pre-sales role before I tell you today
uh that is great right that is already
the first step if you don't know then
you know uh after the session feel free
to do some research you can do research
online there's so much information
online available already you can doing
research by talking to people who's you
know uh already working on this role
right uh what is expected so I think
research is probably a very uh good
first step right and the research on you
know some of the the the the differences
of the rows I was talking about as well
right we have partner essay we have
geolocation for a focus essay industry
essay domain essay you know account
essay you know what are the really the
differences right which one is more
suitable to you
um so that would be probably the first
one once you're knowing that right and
then you think hey you know this group
or you know this one particular right is
something that I'm aiming for then you
can start building your experiences
right preparing uh your interviews your
resumes around that you know a job
around that job or the job families
right uh so those could be getting the
targeted certifications right if you're
a solution architect obviously you know
there's Solutions architect
certifications right from associate two
all the way to professional level
um getting Hands-On projects experiences
right working with architecture design
uh if you're an engineer today you know
a lot of times you you know some of your
senior Engineers start working on system
design right AI getting involved right
or just you know schedule mentoring
session to say hey I'm interested in
that right or schedule sessions with
your CTO right to see hey I want to get
some exposure about how is that done
um so really kind of like build up your
entire you know projects resume around
those things right and then you know
lastly I would say
um
looking at uh you know the the rows
right that's uh opening up right uh that
um
preparing for kind of some of the the
cultural level of things right the the
soft skills level things if you are you
know absolutely interested in the AWS uh
today right then uh as I mentioned that
you know our leadership principles is is
a very core piece that is um kind of you
know uh throughout the interviews right
um as well as you know once you join us
uh throughout your employee cycle as
well it's very much a a part of you know
how how success metrics is defined right
how are you being more you know
um
um kind of you know welcomed recognized
at work as well so familiar yourself
with those leadership principles right
and then don't go just for the headlines
um and so because under each headlines
there is a little bit of paragraph right
that explaining what that means
specifically uh in the Amazon context
because some of the words right with the
if without a paragraph everybody has a
different understanding uh of like earn
trust uh you know are right a lot
um but with the help of that paragraph
you can you know start understand a bit
more hey Amazon might interpret this a
bit differently right so this is what
they are looking for and this is how I
should prepare my resume my interviews
uh my project experiences around what
they're looking at as well yeah
excellent thank you so much Jerry for
all of your advice for this whole hour
there's been a lot of messages in the
chat thanking you for your time and you
know a few comments as well like someone
mentioned that they like Singapore
Hawker centers
um a few funny comments someone said
that they want to they want to buy you
they want to buy you a beer but it's
just everyone just really appreciates uh
your time and thank you so much everyone
for tuning in to today's live stream as
well we had 100 at the moment we have
109 people watching so you know that's
that's honestly amazing
um and hope you all got a lot of value
out of this let me know as well in the
comments if you want to see more live
streams and who else you know like what
are the topics you want me to cover in
these lives but yeah thank you so much
Jerry thanks so much everyone for tuning
in so much Lucy and everyone yeah yeah
we're at time now so I'll let you go now
Jerry uh but yeah remember to connect
with Jerry I just sent after your
LinkedIn by the way in the chat and yeah
this recording or like this live stream
will be available as a recording so if
for anyone who wants to re-watch this
um but okay thanks Jerry thank you so
much and thank you
bye